تهديدات قائد ومؤسس فاجنر ياخذها الكرملين
بكل تاكيد بعين الاعتبار كونا انسحاب هذه
المجموعه يعني انهيارا جديدا لروسيا شرقي
البلاد اذا البدايه من جبهه بخموت هذه
الجبهه التي تسيطر عليها قوات فاجنر
تقريبا على كامل هذه المنطقه هي موجوده
بالوسط وعلى طرفي هذه المنطقه ولكن هنا
مشاهدينا الصراع يتركز الان بالمنطقه
الغربيه لبخموت لاحكام السيطره عليها طبعا
مخموت للتذكير هي تعتبر نقطه وبلده الصمود
وهي عنوان للصمود الاوكراني ومن هنا فان
سقوط هذه البلده يعني سقوط شيء رمزي كثيرا
بالنسبه للاوكران اذا ايضا يعني بموازاه
هذه السيطره اذ هنا يهدد رئيس فاكتور بانه
في حال سقطت هذه الجبهه يعني انهيار
الجبهه باكملها وانسحابها يعنيها ان مناطق
سيطره القوات الروسيه هنا اتحدث عن هذه
المناطق هنا اي عن الديفكا وعن لمن وايضا
المناطق المحيطه بمخموت ننتقل من بخموت
الى سوليدار
ايضا هناك ايضا القوات طبعا قوات موجوده
بهذه المنطقه المحاذيه لبخموض وايضا
التابعه لدونيسكي اداريا مقاتلوا فاغنير
ينتشرون هنا ايضا بهذه المنطقه داخل مناطق
عده لمقاطعه لوغاسك اذا هذه المناطق
السيطره عليها تعتبر استراتيجيه وسقوط
احدى هذه الجبهات كما يهدد مؤسس فاجنر
ايضا سيؤثر على الجبهه جبهه روسيا بموازاه
تحضير اوكرانيا لما اصبح يعلم بالهجوم
المضاد لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات